there is such a thing as truth and that
was the beginning of my wake up call in
order to succeed you have to be always
on because this may be this company
depends on you so most of you already
know if you go online you look at
different news sites Huffington Post is
a site everybody knows about right it's
a top 300 website it's done very very
well for themselves and the founder is
there Yana Huffington for many of you
entrepreneurs out there you know you
build the business to 1 they get a nice
victory where somebody comes in that
possibly says hey we would like to do
something with this and I were sitting
with her talking to her about her
success thank you so much for making a
fellow immigrant yes yes we had a good
time talking about our past and by the
way before we get started do you mind if
I put my phone to sleep here on this
phone bed here can you tell us about
this phone yes so we launched thrive in
December 2016 so just over a year ago
and there was one product that I wanted
to launch at the same time with a
company and that's this phone bed it's
actually a charging station we are all
addicted to a phone what we recommend is
that you put this little phone bed
charging station outside all the
bedrooms in the home and then at night
everybody puts their phones to sleep and
you put them under the blankie you talk
the mean you say good night and the idea
is that why the phone is sleeping and
charging you're sleeping and recharge I
love the idea over 70% of people sleep
with their phones by their bed according
to all the latest science the worst
thing you can do for your sleep is to
sleep with your phone oh yes the phone
is the repository of every project every
problem everything we're dealing with
when we're awake therefore it needs to
be separated from us when we're asleep
and recharging so you can wake up fully
recharged and deal with whatever Life
brings us I'm gonna be a customer thank
you so much you started as a journalist
right and you work your way up as a
journalist and then from there comes you
know Huffington Post what was it in that
moment when you said
I would like to start Huffington Post
and I think was roughly around 2005
right is when that happened what was the
transition for you to go from a
journalist who wanted to start a brand
called Huffington Post so what happened
is that I began to say that the
conversation was moving online before
Facebook and Twitter dominated our lives
and I wanted to create a platform both
for very well-known people who could
theoretically write for the New York
Times or anywhere they wanted and for
people who were students nobody had
heard of or anyone in life with
something interesting to say and I
wanted to elevate blogging on day one we
launched with blog post by Ellen
DeGeneres and Larry David and John
Cusack and Walter Cronkite I became a
platform for interesting voices known
and unknown and also little by little a
very established journalistic enterprise
we won a Pulitzer I wanted the company
to be global you and I as we said
immigrants we believe that you need to
bring the world together so when I left
hospice to launch thrive global we were
in 17 countries including Brazil and
India really so this is 17 countries
that are contributing from their
consoles that Huffington Post that IND
was a gr whatever launched every country
with a partner a major media partners so
the great thing for the interpreter is
watching about doing a start-up the
second time is that you've learned a lot
the first time what's the difference
what's the biggest difference for you
for me personally the biggest difference
is that when I launched 1/2 post I was
living under the delusion in order to
succeed you have to be always armed you
have to sacrifice sleep your health your
relationships everything because this
baby this company depends on you you are
at your best when you are recharged
creative connected to your wisdom and
your best decisions I was completely
wrong at the beginning of launching the
Huffington Post and in fact two years
into launching the Huffington Post I
collapsed from
exhaustion sleep deprivation burnout
what was your schedule like at that time
it was crazy and on top of being in
first time in the preneur I was a
divorced mom of two teenage daughters in
all simultaneously so then I collapse I
hit my head on my desk break my
cheekbone and that was the beginning of
my wake-up call that actually led to
thrive the book and thrive the business
because I recognized that it wasn't just
me who was burnt out burnout and stress
and global epidemics and they're
particularly prevalent among
entrepreneurs mm-hmm who feel
indispensable and who feel that they
have to sacrifice all the things that
actually make us more productive what
change your mindset that you're scared
to become an eight-hour day 10-hour day
what what did you change instantly my
life is very busy
it's not about slowing down it's not
about not being busy it's not about not
working hard
it's about refueling yourself if you had
to pull an all-nighter to ship a product
are you then taking some time to
recharge or do you keep going until you
start making bad decisions oh your
health your health is impaired diseases
are stress-related
mm-hmm are now 75 percent of healthcare
problems and health care costs so we are
dealing with 75% of healthcare problems
which are preventable and stress-related
that is like stunning here's my next
question I want to transition with you
here so you create Huffington Post it
succeeds it comes up it does very well
and there's so many it's a platform
where different people can comment on it
right do you think the idea that I can
wake up today and just be a journalist
and start writing on a website and
create my own blog do you think that
diminishes the industry of journalism
you think that's good for journalism
where somebody just can wake up and
start writing blogs about what they
think about presidential debates is that
a good thing or anything
I think democratizing the media is a
very good thing provided that people
realize that everybody has a right to
their own of
but not to their own set of facts like I
think provided we have a reverence for
truth there is such a thing as truth and
if you are know what is true if you
honor the fact then you can have any
opinion you want but it's on top of
something that you can all agree on we
can all agree this phone bed is here you
may like the phone bed or dislike the
phone bed that's completely your
prerogative but if you say the phone bed
is not here that's the problem we are
having now and I think it's very
important for us to realize the truth is
not always in the middle the truth is
sometimes on one side or the other and
we need to acknowledge that when I turn
on the news you look at Young Turks you
know which way they lean you look at
MSNBC you know which way then you look
at CNN you look at Fox you look at many
of these different sites you go to you
pretty much can tell which way they lean
you're saying facts and truth the other
side's gonna say also facts and truth so
how can somebody decipher all this
information to say what is really the
truth who should I really be listening
to I think there are facts and truth I
mean Donald Trump's invest in a Eurasian
crowd was not the biggest ever which is
what he claimed so you know it's not
like a difficult thing to assess we are
acting as the facts and truth are like
so difficult to assess they're not I
think there are a lot of journalists and
a lot of networks that make it appear as
though it's a difficult thing to assess
in order to confuse and befuddled people
so I think this is particularly
important right now when there are so
many claims of fake news that are not
really fake there are some issues which
are beyond left and right I actually
agree with you there let's take gun
control over 80% of people in this
country believe in background checks
strong background checks and yet we
don't have them this is you don't have
to be on the left to want background
checks you just have to be sane so we
need to stop acting as though everything
is divided into a left point of view and
a right point of fact but I think that's
what the media is down
you think the media's kind of sold it
that way what do we do as the viewer
okay let's just say there's media and
then there's the audience that's
watching the right how do they do proper
research to get the right information
for them what do they the first thing is
that we can no longer just talk about
the media because the majority of people
don't get the news from conventional
media and they get it from social media
and they get it from Facebook they get
it from Twitter so I think we have a
bigger problem which is that as we've
seen with them the abuse of Facebook
advertising by the Russians to impact
our election we have the problem that in
the attention economy a lot of
algorithms are producing a very
dangerous phenomenon which is there if
you are conservative who is anti Obama
and pro Trump they're going to feed you
material that will respond to your
biases and the other way around and they
can even feed you a lot of falsehoods
that you're more likely to believe
because they tend to play into our own
biases so last topic before we wrap up
here is business was there a moment
where you had to learn these you know I
had to learn how to do this this this to
transition from being a journalist to
being a business owner an entrepreneur
because I think sometimes a realtor can
go from being a realtor I learned how to
sell so I learned how to sell properties
to them being a business owner right
what was that transition for him because
you didn't have experience being an
entrepreneur you did a very very you
know phenomenal job with that what were
some things yet to learn I think what I
had to learn is to delegate
I think delegating is incredibly
important
a lot of entrepreneurs think everything
is to go through them and it becomes
really a complete mess because a they
can't possibly know everything and B
they become a stumbling block for
decisions you know if everything has to
go through them so I had to learn to
hire great people and
to delegate not to micromanage so here
let's take a drive I had a fantastic CEO
we used to run Survey Monkey who had a
lot of knowledge about setting up
infrastructures and processes and quotas
for salespeople and Bhanu systems and
all the things you need to get right to
be able to deliver a profitable company
when I left the Huffington Post that
took a couple of amazing people with me
whom I knew extremely well which is also
a great advantage you know one of them
had joined the Huffington Post as an
intern so he had been with me for 12
years and he is now running the global
expansion of life the other one used to
be my chief of staff and he's now
running biz dev so this is just a few
examples of bringing great talent with
you and not living under this delusion
that hey I superhuman know everything
I'm going to do everything because a I
don't know everything and B I'm not
going to be as good if I try to do
everything now will you ever are you
naturally a control person like do you
like to control so was that something
that was hard to give up cuz you know
entrepreneur sometimes they lack control
of everything no absolutely I I just
wanted to know everything and I still
know everything but I found new ways to
know everything and what I say now is
you're on a green light but I know
everything because we have waste where
you're communicating what's happening
and if I see something I don't agree
with I'll interfere but until I do
you're in a green light you don't have
to run every decision by me and that
happened through you realizing that if
you want to build a big you need help of
building up if you want to scale you
know everything is about scaling we just
closed our Series B and raised another
thirty million dollars I saw them
because we wanted to grow faster you
have a lot of advantages if you are a
market leader and to become a market
leader you need to scale quickly and in
order to scale quickly you need to build
a great team in order to build a great
team you have to be willing to Delek
because also if you're a super talented
person you are not going to come to work
for me even if I have you on a leash do
you know what I'm saying hundred percent
so it's not just about my time and my
opportunity to make good decisions it's
also about what people are you
attracting if you're going to attract
superstars which is the only people I
want to attract then you need to give
them a big playground to play excellent
and this is thrive the third metric to
redefining success in creating a life of
well-being wisdom and wonder and I want
to invite everybody to write and tell us
their stories on the thrive platform and
I'm going to give them my email please
do so aah at thrive global.com we'd love
to hear your voices you can tell us your
stories of burnout or you can tell us
your stories of your life hacks or what
you are doing look what that effective
if you've had any of it send an email
directly to her again the link will be
below we're gonna put the link of the
book also below in the description to go
get yourself a copy and I'm gonna wake
up my phone here I think the tap already
woke up my phone but I'm gonna wake up
my phone here and chat see for this
charge you see it's charged and we had a
great conversation we didn't get
interrupted what a great invention this
is right mariana thank you so much
playing sometimes thank you so much for
having us